rouge et blanc les couleurs du pays
basque le sud-ouest étaient à l'honneur
à magny les hameaux pour le téléthon 35e
édition au gymnase chantal mauduit dans
une ambiance festive l'association
objectif téléthon manie quoi créer
depuis 14 ans organise chaque année le
téléthon pour récolter des fonds des
milliers de personnes qui vont venir en
fait pendant ces 24 25 eur et viennent
faire la fête et ils consomment en fait
toute la consommation est intégralement
reversé
les festives au programme de nombreuses
animations basket tir à l'arc ou encore
pétanque les amateurs pouvaient
découvrir une planche qui appartenait à
philippe quintais champion du monde de
pétanque c'est un monsieur qui nous
donne envie de continuer justement la
pétanque et et en espérant que les jeux
qu'on fait ce soir puisse attirer des
jeunes à suivre son exemple
ce sont dix sept mille cinq cents euros
qui ont été collectés durant ce week end
autre ambiance à versailles le pâté en
croûte et est le produit phare pour le
téléthon depuis 24 ans le lions club de
versailles et la charcuterie les délices
du palais s'associent pour réaliser le
record du monde du plus grand pâté en
croûte cette année il fait près de 70 m
la frange et pas 3 euros depuis le
lancement mais les gens donnent souvent
beaucoup plus un euro collecté est
intégralement reversé au téléthon il
faut compter 96 heures de fabrication ça
fait 20 ans que tous les shaks téléthon
je la cherchais mon pâté en croûte il
est très bon c'est sur le plan
gastronomique c'est une belle affaire et
qu'ils ont plus ça aide des gens qui ont
vraiment besoin trouve que c'est une
très bonne initiative
donc le produit sont bons et en plus
c'est paul téléthon chaque année entre
8000 à 9000 euros par an ceux collectés
par les ventes de pâté en croûte plus de
700000 euros ont été récoltés dans les
yvelines